my guest tonight is the Tony Grammy an
Emmy winning creator of the hit Broadway
show Hamilton joining us from his home
in Washington Heights our friend
lin-manuel Miranda sir how are you I
can't believe we're wearing the same
shirt I love that yes it's it's hate and
it's very kind of you to wear a thing I
sent you in the mail yeah well I I'm
pretty easy if you send me something in
the mail I will wear it and I want to
get that message out there but this has
special significance this shirt tell us
about it yes my my family runs a company
called T Rico and we sell merch and we
made this this is actually the zip code
for Times Square and Broadway and all
proceeds of this shirt complete with
elbow kissing elbows goes to the
Broadway cares Relief Fund which helps
fund the Actors Fund and basically
everyone not just actors but everyone
who works in the theater it's it's an
emergency assistance fund for them since
we work where people gather yeah I mean
this is been devastating so this is a
great this is a great cause I will wear
this with pride
okay it picks up the color in my eyes I
think very nicely yeah it cuz really
that's at the end of the day what's the
most important thing you know so many
things to talk about first of all it's
weird we're in a weird situation right
now we're all separated but there's so
many things that unite us right now
these common experiences one of the
things I've been having very vivid
dreams and then I read in the in an
article that everyone's having vivid
dreams right now I understand you posted
about this you're having weird dreams
yeah I dreamt last night or the night
before I posted on Twitter I dreamt I
was like a grizzled newspaper
I didn't order like a JJ Jameson type
and my two Star reporters my Woodward
and Bernstein were Swoosie Kurtz and
wrappered the baby and like they
couldn't be more different but he worked
and I was just like get it to me mom I
just by five o'clock did you have a
little cigar
like I don't know something about this
team I think they're really good at
crack it I wasn't ready what eise was I
just remember no like I feel like my
brain is just looking around like you
get in here
now you have very young kids and they're
playing a lot with these toys and these
little toy figurines which kids do like
animals and stuff like that but you
posted this picture that is fascinating
because it's a bunch of animals it's all
animals I think and exotic animals yeah
and then the rock is in there for some
reason yeah yeah well he doesn't fit any
of the other toy categories I think it
was actually I think it was a toy I had
in college that just landed in my kids
rotation it's of Dwayne the rock Johnson
when he was a wrestler yeah and he's not
a superhero he doesn't fit with the
Barbies he doesn't so he lives in the
Savannah with the Savannah animals and I
get Pride Rock everywhere which means
that like I'll just walk into a room and
they've set up a pride watch situation
where there's a fossa in the middle and
all the animals in an elaborate
arrangement around Texas my shower
Johnson is always there like sort of
amidst the Zebras and the draft
have you ever reached for a bar of soap
or the loofah in the shower and realize
you were scrubbing yourself with Dwayne
the rock Johnson has that happened I've
not yet had that pleasure but I have
stepped on several small animals man
prymaat a lot of us were getting into
self-care and you have really been
taking it to a high level like with the
beard you're doing things with your
beard you've never done before I just I
never used I never had enough hair on my
face I mean if you look at this sad-ass
Cat Stevens thing happening here it's
this is the goatee that knows who it is
I know these guys being like what are we
doing out here
yeah so yeah I've been I've been like
conditioning the beard and just having a
softer facial expression errs for beards
I didn't know that and
and it is it it's uh here's where I made
the mistake of saying I just used my
regular conditioner on a beard and I
said it in a public place does it have
like a nice sandalwood odor does it
smell like a Yankee Candle my face time
to buy a special I guess that's the next
step if I'm going to be a beard bin if
I'm going full offerman yeah I can't do
a full Offerman
no only Offerman can do I've seen
Offerman shave in the morning and then
I've had dinner with him that night and
he's got a full giant grizzly bear yeah
there you go
because some people might think oh the
rest of us are doing nothing but
lin-manuel Miranda he's you know writing
a full-on opera about my beard and
putting lotion on my feet and like
wrapping them up like a marinade
putting your putting lotion on your feet
I am that's my new chick no Alyssa I'm
not a Philistine like I put on like a
lotion shower I put on lotion like a
human person
I don't be employed on us with you I
don't lotion I've never lotion I have
the driest skin in the world I have the
hands of a t-rex yeah well no my feet
were really like kind of cracked because
I've just been running around barefoot
in the house and then my wife said put
like too much lotion on your feet put
socks on like right away and it's like
just like exactly that face lean into
that and then just like just squish it
doesn't it squish around when you're
walking yeah lean into the crevasse just
like go swim down into it strangers feet
at the end of the day coming oh I see
then suddenly they I have I have that
that feeling that that my feet are some
other person's feet which might be very
erotic for myself yes and where might it
take you
you you did a thing which I thought was
really cool which is there's a lot of
people out there young people 17 18
years old who are not going to have
their prom so people have been posting
prom photos and you put up your yearbook
photo
I'm not prom photos but your yearbook
photo just sort of let people know hey
we're with you in spirit you're not
gonna get to have your prom so here's my
yearbook photo you put this thing up and
I have to talk to you about it I love
everything first phone that small the
birth of the beard
yeah the birth of the beard but also the
head is cold I have a unique point of
view
yeah no dates yeah yeah no I uh what's
funny is the kids don't even know this
but that was the picture that ran in our
freshman year Facebook before Facebook
was like a democracy democracy
destroying thing it was a literal book
that had pictures of all of the incoming
freshmen and that's what I advertised to
new kids just it's very it's very Ross
on friends well yours is Ross on friends
I don't know I am gonna show you mine
now yeah me I was such a nice little
girl conditioner they other the
furthering the feathering and the hair I
was I was a yes thank you thank you very
much I was very very proud of that and I
did a good job by the way you mentioned
that was that your son made a drawing in
the background to help promote the show
and he orange glasses and hook for a
hand I think he's used you with some
sort of scary stories to tell in the
dark type situation yeah I love that I
love that
orange glasses and a hook for a hand is
what I mean - your son yes you must be
yeah you must be you must be a God in
your home because you did something you
took part in a very special Sesame
Street and you got to talk to Elmo on
Zoom I did that must have been huge for
your kids it was great
I basically was like well after we
filmed a segment can my kids dog was my
favorite it was amazing I mean my my
kids just you know he's so real to them
in my two-year-old he's got maybe one
brand he recognizes in his life and it's
like Elmo was the first word he said
really clearly before mommy and daddy
feels like Elmo put on Elmo
so like talk to Elmo and Elmo gives them
a thumbs up it was really it was really
awesome it's amazing when you have those
moments where also your kids are
probably looking at you and thinking
wait you're our connection to Elmo you
must have achieved something in this
life I know trust me I know I know it
doesn't it doesn't last for about 5
minutes it doesn't it doesn't get you
anything at all you're of course you're
known for freestyling are you doing a
lot of freestyling and Quarantine right
now only to my friends only in videos
not fit for TV but you know if you
wanted to if you wanted to make up a
song we could do that if you want to
like I'll try it if you like very rusty
yeah that's ok we're we're all playing
on the bar has been lowered for all of
us would you do first thing when you
woke up this morning I overslept I slept
later than I normally do I stumbled out
of bed I made myself a shake with
spinach and some fruit in it hmm
I then and wrestled with my dog what's
loke okay yeah let's see what else did I
do
I did three push-ups what's the most
exciting you know it this is the problem
it's quarantine so this would be it
talking to you this is the highlight of
my day is having as a conference with
lin-manuel Miranda nothing's gonna beat
that you know I had a conversation with
someone in your house this morning that
I don't know someone said something that
maybe they shouldn't have said yes my
son loves to okay boomer me he's 14 and
so all he does is put me down for not
being tech-savvy and I asked him a very
simple question I thought it was a
simple I asked a question that I thought
was interesting about my computer and
setting up the zoom conference and he
was like okay boomer and I what was the
question it was something like when I
hit the spacebar why does it not click
back into the other window something I
don't even understand cuz I'm not good
I'm not good at computers I'm really not
so and I shouldn't be doing anything I
should but we're alone here I don't have
anybody at work I usually had people
come in and go and it's all set and
lin-manuel Miranda's there and go but
now no I have to figure it out right and
we're there any interactions you had
today that we're like actually really
great like heartening like we're gonna
be okay I actually I'm gonna again this
may be cheating but I'm gonna go to you
I like I really like what you're doing I
like what you're doing for Broadway and
theatres and Times Square and and I I
like that I get to wear this shirt that
matches my eyes that was a gift from you
that's a big deal to me so I like that
okay great sorry oh man it was late it
was
I slept till 9:00 this morning I'm sorry
I slept till 9:00 you have wrong kids
yes I do
[Music]
baby
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes that was great yeah you know and I
this this is gonna get me incredible
this is gonna make my son's day because
he's a huge fan huge fan of yours as is
my daughter and so the fact that you
sang this song were you mock me and call
me okay boomer that's he's fired by him
Wow this is this is huge
oh that was fantastic and I will gladly
share the rights to that with you
oh yeah fantastic yeah there was a
little Dana Carvey creeping in because
I've been listening to your Dana Carvey
podcast so always a hats off to the
brilliant Dana Carvey let me make sure
that was fantastic man that was great I
have to say all you need is a little
more time in quarantine polish that up
you've got a great musical about another
important historic figure I want to
mention something you're doing amazing
work in addition to what we've already
talked about you're doing amazing work
with Hispanic Federation and something
called edu ham at home you want to talk
about that for a second yeah sure
they're two different things both sort
of really important right now we've
worked with the Hispanic Federation for
a really long time we worked with them a
lot in the wake of Hurricane Maria but
right now we're setting up an emergency
assistance fund basically because you
know Latino communities have been among
the hardest hit through this pandemic
and so it's an emergency fund for
organizations that already existed or
are
doing great work in fields like Public
Health and immigration and and basically
servicing Latin ex needs and then a jam
I'm really excited about edge a ham is
something we've been doing for years
with the Hamilton show we basically
created a curriculum for schools when
they're coming to visit Hamilton they
write their own pieces they perform them
for us on stage at the Rogers than we do
in QA and we perform the show for them
and we're we're making that curriculum
public so basically if you're bored with
your kids you have the Hamilton
curriculum at your disposal now to
basically learn to create using primary
sources and really excited about that
let me make sure I get the word out to
guess some of the great clothing that
supports Broadway cares kovat 19
emergency fund go-to Chirico comm is
that correct yeah okay we're gonna make
sure that we put that all up here down
at the bottom because we want to get the
word out great
sir you are doing you're doing God's
work I swear to god I'm such a huge fan
and an admirer of you not just as an
artist but a person so thank you thank
you you had to do it didn't you you had
to do it hey thank you so much that was
amazed